oh okay the plutocrats they're throwing
a Hail Mary well I think they're seeing
that Trump is still way ahead in every
single poll big donors are now freaking
out and are trying to Draft Virginia
governor Glenn yunan into the
presidential race according to Robert
Costa that well-known conservative at
the Washington Post the plan is to push
if not shove yunan into it during what
they're calling the red vest retreat in
mid October would you rule this out
rule rule what I rule out jumping into
the race yeah I told I've told you I'm
totally focused on Virginia elections
the whole state has flipped it's working
and this is a case study for what can be
done in other states joining me now
former Speaker of the House new gangri
he's also a Fox News contributor um Mr
Speaker U billionaire Tomas pedy told
the Washington Post that the money is
there if yunin wanted to get in
what what nonsense is this at this point
I mean talk about doing an end run
around the people new they don't they
don't want what the people want the big
donors they just want to control
everything I guess
look I suspect the money is there but
the votes aren't uh I'm I'm a big fan of
Glenn yunan I think he's doing a great
job as Governor I think in
2028 he could be a very impressive uh
maybe even front runner for president uh
but not this time not this year he's
correctly focusing on the legis of races
in Virginia where he has a real chance
to make a difference you know I was
talking to our mutual friend the
pollster Matt to this afternoon and Matt
said to me based on what he saw last
night this race is over Donald Trump
will be the nominee they might as well
quit having the various debates because
they don't work they're not helping
anybody uh and uh I think that's where
we are I think Trump will be the nominee
and the question now for everybody is do
you want to see Joe Biden reelected or
or do you want to help Donald Trump
there's no middle ground here I don't
think uh because you're either going to
get Trump as president or you're going
to get Biden and Biden's re-election
would be a disaster for the country but
I I think you quoted on my podcast today
someone saying Trump now after this last
debate is the reality and defeating
Biden is the necessity so given those
two you know thoughts that the
conservatives I I imagine most of them
see now I I mean now what are people
going to stop start dropping out and
endorsing Trump or are they just going
to hang out until super
Tuesday well I think I mean I think the
Republican National Committee should
cancel the future debates and say look
uh we recognize the objective fact that
Trump will be the nominee we want to
work with him and then the next big
hurdle is a totally corrupt judicial
system which is trying every way it can
uh to deny the American people uh the
right to have the candidate that they're
choosing I mean Trump in some of these
races some of these polls Trump is like
43 points ahead of the next person 43
points uh he's going to be the nominee
and I think it tells you how terrified
the left is that they're doing
everything they can legally because they
can't do anything politically uh given
the economy given everything else that's
going on I think the odds are very high
that Trump will win the general election
and they're going to do everything
everything they can to stop that but n
what about my idea that I floated last
night um on Hannity show that if we're
going to have any debate why not a
debate between Nikki Haley and Ronda
santis I know they're doing their the
debate with on Newsome but to me that
would be interesting maybe no moderator
just the two of them discussing
discussing maybe three or four big
issues because that that would actually
be fairly entertaining and I think would
maybe learn
something look I I think there there
were a number of smart people on stage
last night uh and I think that you're
right if they were in a setting where
they could have a real conversation uh
they would be more interesting people
but it wouldn't help them it would not
help any of them uh get to be the
nominee because the fact is very few
people are going to watch if I don't
know what the numbers were last night
but they're going to be worse if if
there is a third debate it'll have
virtually no viewership it'll have no
impact except in the news media uh and
so uh I mean I like Nikki Haley a lot I
think she's very smart and did a great
job at the UN and a great job as
Governor I think Rond do sanis is an
amazing Governor uh and has been about
as effective as you could be and in
other circumstances I suspect he'd be
the front runner but we are where we are
uh Trump is not really a candidate he is
the leader of a national movement and
that's a totally different psychological
and emotional relationship than
candidacy so I think the question now is
can we stop the justice department and
the various legal assaults and remember
they're not just attacking Trump they're
trying to block Robert F Kennedy Jr
they're trying to block the No Labels
people I mean the Biden model is if I
can keep everybody off the ballot and I
have no opponent I'll probably win uh
which is which is insane I mean is so
unamerican that to have him lecture the
rest of us on Democracy frankly uh makes
my stomach churn no we're about to have
um Doug bergham and um VI ramaswami on
the show so if they want to be
considered
future uh candidates for the presidency
maybe in a cabinet or what what would
you suggest that they do now really
quickly well look look I've been a
candidate I know that you get in there
you you always have hope they're going
to point out that nobody's even voted
yet and they'll think I'm being
presumptuous my advice would be endorse
Trump uh campaign across the country get
better known uh I I thought Doug beram
given his practical real life experience
in business given the great job he's
done in North Dakota he clearly should
be in a cabinet I think ramas Swami has
an amazing future he's 38 years old and
I think you know he's he's going to do
well but all these folks are good people
uh is it wasn't that any of them were
bad people it is that none of them is in
the same league as Donald Trump and none
of them is in a position to say with a
straight face I can take on the en
National establishment have them beat me
up for eight years and still be
cheerfully out here campaigning Trump is
a phenomenon he's unlike anything I've
seen no we're gonna have him on so we'll
bring it up thank you so much hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else